Ukraine's main Inland Port seen here
from the Romanian side of the Danube
River was attacked overnight putting
another hurdle between Ukraine's grain
and its customers they went to sew to
the whole world and to soup owners that
the boards of Ukraine the boards offered
this region are dangerous Russia quit
the U.N Black Sea grain deal July 17th
it had created a humanitarian Corridor
that allowed roughly 33 million metric
tons of grain and oil seeds to be moved
out of Ukraine Rob Hubert is a military
strategist it's bleeding remember the
one of the elements of the Russians is
to bleed the enemy you you know this is
why the Russians traditionally haven't
had that much of a concern when they're
hitting civilian targets
the Kremlin stated the attacks in the
Danube targeted facilities housing
foreign Fighters military hardware and a
Naval Shipyard Russia has been accused
in recent weeks of once again using food
as a weapon of War system
in his nightly message the Ukrainian
president said they are working to
strengthen air defense systems
units like this gephard based in the
Kiev region have been the only line of
defense against attacks on
infrastructure sites the Odessa region
has been hit numerous times in recent
weeks officials won't comment on how
many air defense units are in the area
saying only more are needed all the
poets are endangered
they could be attacked by the enemy in
the future Danube River ports like the
one in Ismail are a Lifeline in moving
Ukrainian food products to neighboring
countries and then on to customers
outside of Europe
Crystal gomancing Global News London